Both the iPhone XS Max and the new Samsung
Galaxy S10 are incredibly powerful phones,
so powerful that they’ve surpassed what
even the best games and apps available on
either app store can take advantage of.
So is there really a point to run speed test
comparisons anymore?
Who cares.
Let’s do it anyway.
We’re gonna throw some benchmarks in at
the end, but we’re gonna focus on tests
that you’ll notice in real life, unlike
the unrealistic RAM management tests we see
all over YouTube.
Let’s start with which phone can boot up
quicker.
The iPhone hits the lock screen only slightly
quicker than the Samsung, but after unlocking
them, we saw that the S10 was still booting,
which is surprising.
Next, let’s see which one loads and plays
a YouTube video first.
The S10 started playing considerably quicker,
and this is actually something you’ll notice
in day-to-day use.
We tested this multiple times and the S10
was quicker basically every time.
Next up, let’s load some of the most common
apps people use, like Instagram.
Again, the S10 finished quite a bit sooner.
Now with Facebook, we see the same result
once again.
So far, we’re really impressed with the
speed of the S10.
Snapchat is used pretty often, so let’s
test that.
And there you have it, that’s the nail in
the coffin.
The Samsung is consistently loading apps quicker
than the XS Max.
Now let’s test LTE speed, both using T-Mobile’s
unlimited LTE network in our office.
Google’s internet speed test shows the S10
to be slightly faster.
Let’s see what Ooklas speed test shows.
Surprisingly, the XS Max got around 10Mbps
faster in this test, so we reran the test
and found that the S10 was now faster, so
we’re not sure how accurate this app is.
Next up, let’s download some games and see
which one finished faster.
Starting with Fruit Ninja, the S10 seems to
be pending for quite a while before it actually
starts downloading.
Due to this, the XS Max finishes quite a bit
sooner.
Let’s try another one.
Now downloading Toon Blast, the S10 is doing
the same thing again, and it ends up taking
quite a while longer to download and install.
Now let’s see which phone loads web pages
quicker.
In the first run, the S10 was a good amount
quicker to load.
This is something you’ll experience every
day, so we’re pretty impressed.
Surprisingly, on the second run, the XS Max
loaded the images quicker, even though it
seemed to start loading later.
Loading Apple.com is quicker on the S10.
Same with loading the iPhone XR product page,
and the XS Product page as well.
Overall, the S10 loads web pages noticeably
quicker.
Now let’s see which phone loads some games
quicker, starting with everyone’s favorite,
Fortnite.
Surprisingly, the iPhone XS Max finished 16
seconds sooner than the S10, which will easily
make a difference for gamers.
Let’s try some smaller games, like Clash
Royale.
Both phones loaded this one at basically the
exact same time.
Now in Clash of Clans, the S10 finished quicker,
but not much at all, so you won’t really
notice a difference in the real-world.
We also decided to test camera shutter speed,
and there’s a considerable amount of lag
while using the S10, which is pretty unfortunate
since the XS Max snaps a photo instantly.
This may be a big deal for some, and that’s
definitely me.
Now let’s finish off with some benchmarks,
starting with Geekbench 4.
From the looks of it, there’s not much of
a difference in raw multi-core power, but
a great difference in single-core.
Considering that the XS Max has half the RAM,
it’s pretty impressive.
In the popular Antutu graphics benchmark,
the S10 actually beats the XS Max by about
25,000 points, which is really impressive.
We’ve seen scores as high as 350,000 on
the iPhone, but they may have updated the
app recently.
In Antutu’s HTML5 test, the XS Max beats
out the S10, but it doesn’t match the results
we saw earlier in browser speed.
Finally, in GFXBench’s famous 1080P Manhattan
offscreen test, the iPhone scored around 119
FPS compared to 102 on the S10, which are
both great scores.
Overall, we’re really impressed with the
Galaxy S10+.
It scores very high in benchmarks and it seems
to load apps that we all use in day-to-day
life just a little bit quicker than the iPhone.
In some cases, the XS Max was quicker, like
loading Fortnite, but that’s about it.
Either way, both phones are incredibly quick
and it’ll be hard to notice a difference
in real life, but from our testing, the S10
is definitely the winner here.
We’re gonna be testing more things like
the cameras, battery life and gaming performance
in Fortnite, so if you’re not already subscribed,
click that button right there to sub now!
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next video!